so our next speaker is jose Pinot Deb
pronounced that correctly yeah Tino you
know so you know he knows been a member
of the PI data meet up Berlin since last
year in summer he was there for our for
our first for our first meetup adds an
ox at the time and he works at get your
guide and get your guide has also been a
host for the for the PI data meetups in
Berlin and he actually works in
marketing I believe yeah and he's going
to tell us a little bit about the
lessons he learned from applying PI data
to a marketing organization so let's
have a big round of applause for Pinot
thank you for the introduction yes he
said I work with in the marketing
organization in the data science team
that right now is me hopefully it won't
be any more soon and for a couple of
years had get your guide we've been
trying to build what some people like to
call our marketing intelligence to or a
marketing technology to be smarter about
how do how we do marketing and we
believe that central part of this
success that we got it sends to the PI
theta the PI data stack that give the
right tools for us to do it so what we
actually do marketing is not the next
big thing we do a traditional
performance marketing in search engines
and also the way we use the PI data
stack is not a total revolution we don't
have any secret piece of software that
is magic but the way we combine the two
of them to generate business value we
think is something we are proud of and
we want to talk about to other people in
Berlin so first I'm bragging what what
did we reach with that so in less than
one year we have we are doing three
times more marketing in Google that we
used to do and you know is not only a
matter of spending a lot of money on
that is a matter of reducing things like
the time is spent on creating a new
it so one year ago one marketing person
should go there and figure out how to
create an ad something that was relevant
for the user and something that will end
up giving us money and that part is
almost totally automated right now we
launched in seven new markets in six
different languages and I think the
impressive part of it is that we did it
without growing the marketing team and
with the we did it without buying any
expensive marketing software I don't
know if you are aware of how much this
kind of performance marketing software
can cause but could be like ten percent
of how much you spend in search engines
which is a lot and we also didn't have
to hire people that are an expert in the
language in the language that we are
covering we we can hire people who are
experts in marketing so but before all
if I have to say what are the two things
if I go back in the time I joined
categorizing 15 months ago what I will
tell myself be aware of these the first
one will is you're not going to go
anywhere without domain expertise so you
better either like marketing work or you
better are motivated to learn marketing
because we've been see we've seen people
who tried to do it without really
understanding what marketing is and in
particularly in particular marketing in
search engines and they didn't go too
far some of the cases I am aware of in
different companies is like companies
that try to build a machine to create
ads and the output is so bad that they
never use it some of the other cases is
machines that try to predict was the
beat the beat that you should put to
some particular campaign and actually
the bit that what the machine was
building was negative so this kind of
mistakes are those that that you're
going to avoid the view really
understand what is happening there as I
as I said it's not really rocket science
another guy is very typical when you as
a data scientist 22
your data sets and try to come up with
some conclusions usually they come up
with obvious things that everybody knows
like the more I spend the more
visibility I get and things like that
and the single important thing is that
marketing is is a really fast
competition I was talking to someone
else who also works at doing the ad
technology and he told me we have to be
very very very fast because what I need
now if I try to develop it in six months
in six months is going to be completely
useful useless so I have to build some
infrastructure and on top of that be
very very fast analyzing the data or
collecting the data that i need and
making the decisions 11 trade of the job
is have is yeah I could maybe get the
perfect answer if i work 11 week on this
but i don't need the perfect answer in
one week i need the perfect the best
answer I can get today for instance
usually when I'm doing one of analysis
of something i usually put some time
limits to myself I say okay I'll get
these in half a day or in one day if not
it doesn't it doesn't is not worth to
spend more time on it and before I go
ahead I know that many people are not
aware that there's a company in Berlin
called get your guide so get your guide
is a marketplace to tourist activities
what we sell these things like what you
can see there if you want to do one of
these hop-on hop-off tours in a alone in
London or if you want to do a bike tour
in Barcelona you can go to a single
market plates and found find all of them
you can use the app you can use a
desktop version of our website or
whatever you want and this is also
relevant and also determine the kind of
problems we have to solve so I'm
probably already mentioned things like
marketing technology at technology
performance marketing but sometimes I
forget that I have to explain some of
the basics so if you search for day
formal definition of what our technology
marketing technologies is as simple as
create control and target or language
but broke that probably doesn't tell you
much so what is create an ad well is
creating ads that are relevant to the
user of course you need them to click
and you also need Google to consider
them relevant for them when you add in
the case your premium and then you have
to be aware of the limitations of the
advertisement service when you are in
organics in organic results you cannot
only you cannot just pay more and and be
on top you can do that with when you're
paying for it but also you have some
limitations when you create an app you
have some constraints in the number of
words you can put there and even in the
trademarks that you can use and things
like that another part that is a bit of
creating a nod and a bit of controlling
what you do with your ads is also
sending it to the best landing page you
have you have to try to send those user
to the page of this most relevant for
them then there's the control part that
is basically get a lot of data and try
to make some conclusions out of it when
do I have a small as small as painting
marketing or something like that or your
website is not very big you can do it
with one person maybe but when you have
a marketplace that wants to go to too
many too many different markets and that
want to spend a lot you need to collect
this data in an organized way as I'll
explain later and the kind of things
that you have to decide is how much I
should pay for each customer how much do
we expect to receive from every campaign
that we start what are the ranking
factors in SEO you have to watch some
things happening in your website that
might impact how you rank in Google and
at some point someone will ask you how
good are you doing are you hitting your
target you have to ask yourself what is
your target as well and also how much I
can improve this if I keep spending more
money on it am I going to get more
return so these are some parts
the control part of the marketing
technology and also another very
important part is the target first of
all nowadays insert changes there's only
one thing that matters to too many
companies that are the keywords you need
to collect a lot of keywords and then
even more difficult than that is to
decide which ones are relevant for you
and that's something that it also took
us some time to figure out we have a
very complete very complex system to do
it that didn't work and I'll talk a bit
about it then you have remarketing lists
when someone comes to your website you
can then showing that to him on facebook
or something like that then more and
more now with social networks or with
displaying in mobile apps you have to
reach people that are not in this
shopping mode and that also haven't have
never visited your website before so how
do you figure out if this is a person
who is relevant for you and that wants
to buy something for you and of course
you have to target them in their
language and sometimes even figure out
what they write the language for them if
someone is using an English browser in
Germany sometimes you get ads in German
some sometimes you get ads in English
and if you are free submitted in a
website for France you might get ads in
French so if you try to put some
organization into this I would say you
have to you need three steps the first
one is set up the infrastructure of
tools you have to decide what you're
going to do to do everything and then
you have to do the data retrieval and
storage in a different in different ways
and then you can go to the fun part and
the part that probably everybody likes
here that is analyzing the data
automating what what you do doing some
machine learning and some more complex
is statistics so how do you build the
infrastructure of tools so honestly I
was not very very involved on these but
I'm aware that it was something that
took us a lot of time first of all you
you have to ask yourself do I really
need a production server to do this it
depends on
big respect your marketing efforts to be
and then you have to ask yourself what
are my knees do I need to schedule
request do I need to queue this request
for api's do I need to process things
that I'm going to run in multiple nodes
do I need to start at this data how so
for instance some of the decisions that
we have to make is that we needed to
include in our infrastructure salary and
rub it in q2 Bay be able to 2q these
messages and send them at the right rate
to the Google API otherwise AdWords will
say sorry you are going too fast for us
another decision that we did is that
with these cues we can send we can send
these stars two different notes we don't
need very complex analytical queries to
distribute the notes or a Hadoop cluster
for it sometimes we need to use more
than one node to to process and one of
the neverending discussion is when do I
really need a database ya sali put my
date in a structured way in an
unstructured way was the right solution
for that and maybe also the next points
are also relevant for that do we really
need to my my system really needs to
talk to other servers in the
organization in our case we we thought
on is it seems like what we do sometimes
overlap a lot with what the business
intelligent team does so let's use this
the same database solution and that
seemed to be very right because in the
end right now we are all the time
pulling data from our data warehouse
instead of our production servers and
they are also pulling data from our
marketing server to make some high-level
reports and yet another another question
that we got very ground at the beginning
do I really need an interface for the
for this you have to think who is going
to be the user that is going to use it
and how you can let him interact with
your system at the beginning we thought
that Oh what we actually need these are
light framework to the web like flask
and in the end we ended up almost not
using it at all almost everything we do
right now is an episode notebook we
train marketing people to understand
what the notebook is doing to operate it
a bit to shoot it down to running to
modify some variables and that is
actually way more powerful interface
than whatever you can do with flask and
of course another decision we have to do
is like if we're going to have this
production server how we are going to
deploy for that for that the solution we
found this fabric that works pretty well
and automate most of the tests we need
to do for the deploy and then it comes
the part of let's start this data once I
have all my infrastructure I can a
scheduled message and then I need to
model the data that way I'm going to we
are going to receive we have to model
the data because we decided to store it
in a structure way so what we actually
do is like okay we know this data we
want to have it the structure but at the
same time we we know that this is very
fast our requirements what we need is
changing of almost every month so what
we use is Olympic that help you keep
track of the changes that you do in the
database you just write the code it
makes the changes and then if you go you
need to change between versions you can
do it actually I think the other day I
was sick in the start and in something
like 600 days we had 250 different
versions of our schemas so I think that
give you a good feeling of why you need
this kind of software and how really
fast this is changing and and of course
something that is very very painful for
us is when we have to connect to third
party party aap ice so of course as you
can there are things that you cannot
avoid like if you are doing AdWords you
have to connect to add words to download
the reports and the performance data
that you have there you cannot avoid
that but you have to be prepared to have
a migration whenever the one at the one
it because they have senses of the API
and for that we realize way too late
that
although we have to go back go fast we
have to write the better code that we
can because then we have to maintain
that I'm a great dad and I know another
mistake that we we made was relying on
third party system we spend some time
connecting to an API of a company that
give us some visibility matrix actually
these visibility metrics were pretty
simple we're no brainer and in the end
when we wanted to scale that with this
company said oh no but if you want to to
do it with more keywords and with more
requests you're going to have to pay at
seeds of of money and we said for the
service you offer your offer is not
really worth so what we had to do is
back up and start again with a different
API that give us only the google results
and from that we can compute the
visibility that we have in the beginning
we even did everything by ourselves
juice scraping google but that also has
a cost in your time and another thing
that easily they were talking about how
to optimize your code for a speed and
one of the interesting things and i
totally agree that every time you have
to optimize you have to analyze the
costs and the benefits because there's
always a cost even when it looks like a
quick wing I just say oh yeah I'll do
this and I'll get it ten times faster
that's always a cost there it might be
the maintaining this code or in the time
that you spend doing this optimization
and yes I said we use this gray @escape
google so how can you scrape that
without being bang you might also scrape
some other websites that are relevant
for you to get keywords or to get some
competitor analysis you need to strut
data from other system of the
organization and you have to do it in
our orchestrated wave and then you have
the always very dangerous input of users
right many times your system break is
because they use are dealing input the
right thing and we have the the input of
users in our system directly and also to
other systems that we then fight and we
have to be very careful with that
sometimes because sometimes our ads are
not relevant or
stop working and maybe we suddenly start
to spending a lot of money in a keyboard
we really really don't want and then
there's the part of analyze and automate
that this as I said at least the fun
part for me and still here you have to
make some decisions like if I start this
in a database when is the right tool SQL
or pandas like I really believe that if
you have data storing in a database you
don't want to load everything and then
do the filter in there do what you want
to use SQL as a selection tool and at
the same time if you try to do complex a
private table with SQL you're going to
is going to take you more time than just
simply doing it with panda that is great
for that also when when you joined you
have to consider what's best for you and
another thing that is really really low
technology and I was very very surprised
how big was the impact in the way we we
were working was use scheduling queries
to provide data for the spreadsheets
that many people in the organization use
every day and the cool thing is that
right now we automated it use a bit and
every person can you say okay I want to
put this query that copied to this file
and we'll run it every night and they'll
have the data in the spreadsheet every
morning the super low technology that
had a huge impact for their operations
and yet the final part is that all these
tools that they use to create their
campaigns or to change beads or whatever
they actually have a lot of limitations
and for some reason sometimes companies
on bothered enough to provide the right
tools for them so you have to build a
small piece of software on top of that
to allow them to make the changes they
cannot do with the normal interface so
some examples of questions that we had
to answer and a bit of how we also
answer that like what are the products
that people show interested at this time
of the year so what we did for that is
oh actually the we discovered that the
fastest way of doing that is just using
pandas is has
like great connector to Google Analytics
we can analyze what are they landing
page results for some period of time
random page results for another period
of time join the two data frames and
computing the answer from that is very
very easy customer segmentation and what
are the best attributes two segments and
so one of the things that we did is when
we have all our aggregated data of let's
say a very low grint very low grade
segment we have to figure out how we
group them and how we organize it in a
way that it has meaning for for the
business one of the good ideas we had it
was they just tryna random forest or
juice a regression tree and let's see
what are they lazy decisions at the
regression tree takes about the data set
and that was actually a very good idea
to day decide what are going to be the
final segments that we were going to use
in the in the data set and another
question that is not totally resolved
for us is how to estimate the potential
size of a market that I don't know so
nobody in our organization knows
indonesian still we would like to know
what is the benefit of entering the
indonesian market and we want to to do
it without spending two weeks on it so
we have to find the solution or to
automate this we have right now a
solution not a very complete one another
thing we do a lot as I said first
scraping Google then with a third party
aap I know with a different third party
API is monitored the important changes
in ranking you want to know when your
chunk when your how your ranking what is
your performance and also what is the
change is some performance of other
people and of course what are my
competitors doing there another thing
another point that I really like is how
to find the Elias that really need human
attention in an account is that as
obvious as it sounds and it depends on
what you are searching for you will end
up with a different answer
we also try to guess what are the most
important keywords for each page of
course and I'll talk a bit more about
that and what also what are the products
that I have in my marketplace not only
what we can do in marketing also what we
can challenge other teams in the company
to to get for us and some samples
related to mature and machine learning
I'm sure you want to hear about is one
of the questions that we try to predict
is when we are going to sell out this
product is not is not obvious but in the
end what we try to do is that we see we
try to see what is the interest in a
product at the beginning and based on
that we try to to guess what's the
interest in the product in the last days
and with that we can infer how many of
them we are going to sell another one
I'll show you a bit this sentiment
analysis on our customer reviews we have
the ratings of the reviews but that many
many times is not enough some people say
yeah like this product five stars and
then leave a very bad review about it in
your website and usually what ecommerce
websites do to try to increase
conversion is just show the best one but
the best one based on only on the
ratings that the person gave we also did
regressions of what is our return of
other spend we basically want to know if
we spend more we are going to get more
and in which cases we are going to do it
like that and another important decision
was how to cluster our ad groups to make
decisions of them so if you have some
campaigns on ad groups and you don't
have enough data to make a decision on
it you have to group it with some other
that are silly similar and then make a
decision so the solution that we that we
found is this kind of agglomeration
cluster algorithms similar to ward or
something like that to group things that
are relevant and our stopping condition
is stop joining this cluster whenever
they are statistically significant and
yeah I want to show a thing I mean time
so I want to show to you a bit where's
my brother oh sorry my brother is a
closed somehow I try to go back to that
at the end of the presentation if i have
time i wanted to show a bit how we did
the sentiment analysis of customer
reviews i can just explain it so the
decision we have to make here is similar
to what explained before we want to do
send sentiment analysis of our reviews
but we want to do it in a fast way so
shall we do all the process of doing a
classification of what is a good review
for us with this a bad review for us and
do everything and actually the solution
that we found is that there was a
library that are already trained already
trained a model in a lot of in a lot of
English messages to say to the trade to
tell if it's good or if it's bad so you
already have the model out there train
you just have to use the library throw
your reviews to it and then it will give
you a scar and then your decision should
be what to do with this car so this is
actually just a half a day hack I did
during the hack days of the company and
what I wanted to see is over the time
are the reviews that people are living
in our websites better of wars and you
can see that last year in the pic times
the in the summer season for us the
number of positive reviews increase and
while the number of neutral reviews was
kind of the same as in the previous
season the same with the negative
reviews what means that from the
messages we get in the reviews our
customers seems to be more satisfied
with us of course you have many other
ways of measuring this in a company and
this is the dis de praga was talking
before about what are the keywords that
are relevant for us and when I arrived
actually this was our plan it looks very
complex probably very cool to show to
your boss I'm doing all these things the
problem is that when we were halfway
there we found out that
it was useless our approach that it was
very complicated about using a lot of
different sources to get the keywords
then finding some synonyms doing some
natural language processing and some
clustering and finally then deciding
where where to send this user was not
useful to create our ads to target our
users and we what we end up doing it is
just limit ourselves to a part of it
that is using some inputs from the
organization and then do some template
based approach so of course complex many
times means worse and what I also want
to share with you is that we are also
learning and one of the difficult things
we are going through is actually hiring
and growing the team because we have a
good idea of how the team should look
like but it's difficult to find the
right people right we all say we the
idea we have is that they're two
different profiles we want to have data
scientists that are these guys exploring
essentially this is a pretty bad image
because you know all this system is
total [ __ ] but that's what people
usually think of that the scientists and
we want people that are very good at the
statistic are doing forecasting at using
statistical tools and at the same time
we want to have in the team engineers
that are good at databases at machine
learning algorithms so the metaphor is
that the data scientist is this guy who
is searching for water doesn't really
know where it is but is doing an
exploration and finally we have
engineers that can make the most out of
it and the other big question we keep
asking ourselves as a marketing
organization is are we really being
successful because it's not only about
having a prediction I think okay this
prediction was this good or it was this
bad it's also about was the impact for
four of that when we make a wrong
prediction about what's the bit that we
should set for a particular campaign
that has a cost sometimes that is higher
or the dis
and we want to know that to push in the
right direction the business so yeah if
you have to remember something in six
months of this talk i wish this is what
you will remember the first thing is
that yeah we know that market is not the
latest buzz words the people are not
like crazy to work in marketing teams
but it's really fun for people that are
data-driven and I'd want to splurge data
sets or do machine learning then the
mall another thing that is takes a lot
of a lot of time for people to realize
this was the impact of adding technology
to your marketing organization people
think of organizations when they are
engineers in one side and then marketing
people in a different one in complete
different rooms and don't almost don't
talk to each other orally through
requirements and and the third one is
that if you try to do that I'm pretty
sure the PI data stack is going to
provide the right tools for you to do it
because we did it before and we are very
happy with it so that's all or
everything I wanted to say so let's go
45 minutes of questions
and Kewpie know and we have some
questions from the audience you talk
very briefly about how you assess
whether or not you're reaching the right
people mm-hmm it's one of the things I'm
dealing with right now so has wondered
how you assess the value of any
individual customer in some way they can
be validated in the machine learning
sense so what you just really want to do
when you're paying for those customers
is what's the revenge that this customer
is given to me so usually we talk in
terms of revenue per click and then was
also how much we are paying for that
click this group of customers k came
from so does the cost per click so we
analyzed was the revenue per click and
what is the cost per click and then we
try to do predictions and what we try to
predict is what is going to be the
ravine you that this group of customers
is going to have in the future so we've
keep buying people who are searching for
yveltal we're from France what is going
to be the Romanian the next month and
this is where it becomes a bit difficult
because sometimes you don't you don't
know enough you don't have enough data
so it's not significant and this is
where the problem of clustering cluster
in them comes clear okay any more
questions so if there's no more
questions let's thank the speaker once
again
you
you